في امسيه رمضانيه مواجهه ساخنه بين خمسه
لاعبين في مواجهه خمسه اخرين في مباراه في
دوري بين الاحياء السكنيه في مدينه سلا
المغربيه تلعب كل دمك شاركو
ماهر من اي بلاصه كيجيو يتفرجوا هنايا
والحمد لله حنا فرحانين الفراقي ديال
اولاد الحومه
ديما قبل الفطور ان شاء الله
يناديه تلاميذه في كره القدم بعمي حسن هو
الرئيس المؤسس للجمعيه الحسنيه في سلا
الجديده مدرب ومنظم للدوريات الكرويه
المصغره بين الاحياء السكنيه منذ عشرين
عاما ناكل عام كنديروها الدوري هذا
رمضاني باش كنبعدو من الاخطار
الرياضه مهمه للانسان احنا كنعقلوا
لاعبين موقعين
مشرف كبير
في حي اخر في مدينه سلا وعلى بعد نصف ساعه
من رفع اذان المغرب في يوم رمضاني تتواصل
بحماس اطوار مباراه بين عشاق الساحره
المستديره بين ناديين محليين سلايين يجد
مغاربه متعه في المشاركه في دوريات
رمضانيه لكره القدم دوريات تجري مبارياتها
في الساعات الاخيره من يوم الصيام عادل
الزبيري العربيه مدينه سلا بقرب العاصمه
المغربيه الرباط